- What we're doing today is
we're building a dream house
and that really is a translation
of what is important to people.
- It starts with this, or
otherwise it's just some kind
of abstract kind of
spatial artistic piece,
it kind of starts with you got people
who need to be housed or
go to work or do something.
- So, I tend to like really simple forms,
and I'm intentionally choosing
the same color as the base
just so it kind of looks like
there's a seamless connection
between the base and this mass.
- The house is really kind of
most simple type of building
one could build, you know
a space for your bed,
a space for a kitchen,
a space for a bathroom,
so because it's so simple it
actually can be a container
for really, really big ideas.
- So the first thing that
you want to think about
your ambition, your vision
of what your idea is,
so what I'm trying to do, and
we'll see how successfully
we do this, is build a
house around a library.
- I draw inspiration from traveling,
so when I walk around I pay attention
to environments and spaces.
I don't really notice people.
- If you look at this, these
are a flow of material pieces
that can be built up into something,
and taken apart and used again,
and the future of architecture
really should be more like this.
Something that you kind of engage with
rather than something being hidden.
- So I'm sticking with a very
monochromatic color palette
which is kind of very
typical of architects.
Like these really bright
colors scare me a little bit.
- The yellow is a color that
will stand out the most,
so we're going with yellow
as our most important element today.
- It's not just the visual things,
I mean you're looking at pattern
and color and all of that,
but it's the way that it
feels when you kind of walk in
like the feeling of a
wood floor underneath you
is radically different
from a piece of stone.
I mean we do have whole
regimes of sensory input
that we're subject to
everyday that we don't pay
that much attention to, but if you do
it kind of changes the
way that you see things.
- Design is definitely
an iterative process,
you know you kind of
have to test your ideas.
Your first one is usually
not gonna be great
(laughs) which is fine.
- Being able to iterate
is absolutely crucial
to what it is we do because you possibly
cannot get it right the first time.
- One of the things about
architecture that's kind of fun
is when things don't go right.
It has to be the thing that
kind of turns your gears
when you're faced with
a limit or something
you kind of stop and say,
"Hmm, really, does that have to be so?
"Does that necessarily
have to be a limit?"
- Creativity can tend to come
out of a lot of restrictions
just because you have to work within that
and that's common for
a lot of architecture
cuz you're trying to conform
to a lot of zoning regulations
and building code, also
client requirements, budget,
like there's so many constraints
you tend to have to be very
creative with your solutions.
- It's really a profession
all about where you dream
and then you see your dream and
your vision come to reality,
to fruition and that's
really quite marvelous.
- Lately a lot of people who've
gotten architecture degrees
have left the profession and have gone
into game design and things like that.
Some of Nike's head shoe designers
were trained as architects.
- And it's really important for us
to understand architecture the way
we would understand music, the
way we would understand dance
because it is the beautiful
qualities of the spaces
we live in, we work in, we play in,
it's constantly surrounding us.
- Like Instagram and social
media, there's a lot of feature
on architecture and design now,
so people are starting to
see it as something of value
and why it's worth investing in.
Most architects that I
know, you kind of see it
as a calling, as something
you're very passionate about.
- So if you imagine someone's
kind of walking across
the front of there, and I've kind of used
the colors instrumentally but you can see
the kind of layers of the
house as you move through
and how the windows are
getting a little bit
smaller and smaller and smaller,
so as a pedestrian walking by the front
the house doesn't feel
like it's totally shut off
that if there's trees and
stuff back here you'd be able
to see all the way through,
and also it creates this
false sense of depth.
So imagine that this is
the front door, right,
so we have our rather large windows.
This could be the kitchen.
Imagine that we've kind
of completed these parts
but that this is kinda still open,
so you have a garden
that's kinda separating
the public pieces at
the front of the house
from the more kind of
private pieces of the house.
That element is actually
also kind of worked
it's way around out here
so with here you can
kind of see the depth,
so again we're trying to
create these connections
through this way and kind
of stitch the building
together from a conceptual
experience point of view,
so there is your mock-up for a house.
- This is my house (laughs).
So this is like the living
area in this white block,
and this is the main mass
that sort of providing
shading for the building.
I did leave a lot of openings
on this top portion to allow,
I'm imagining sky lights and things here,
so there's lots of like
deep light penetration,
so this is sort of like
a little car park area,
and then this is just more
to frame an open courtyard
that would be landscape and outdoor area.
- So all this yellow box is my library
that extends through the entire side,
and it holds and brings
the whole house together
and then the house is
not necessarily divided
into living rooms, or
dining rooms or bedrooms.
Most of the house feels like it's blank.
What I'm imagining there that there's
a big piece of glass in here
so that glass allows you
to look at the water,
hear the water singing,
have the sea figuratively
come into the house.
Back in here is what I'm
imagining is where you enter from,
so this is space where
we share our library.
That's a space where I
experience it only by myself.
No one really else is
allowed to go in there,
so the library really does
extend through the whole piece,
and it's really something
that brings the experience together.
(light music)